let's go next to spencer from california
spencer you're on
hey david uh thanks for taking my call
so to give a bit of background i'm
currently a student and one topic that
i'm not knowledgeable in is financial
literacy okay partly just because it was
never taught in school and i haven't
learned from my parents either
so my question is twofold first what are
some resources for people in a similar
situation to get up to speed and second
do you think this is something that
should be taught in schools and starting
what
i think that financial literally
literacy should absolutely be taught in
school probably starting in third or
fourth grade i think there's ways to to
start teaching these things in ways that
will
be uh relevant to um kids at you know
eight nine ten years old about budgeting
and spending you can do things in the
classroom where you know you put little
bits of money aside and we say these are
going to be saved so that later we as a
class can do something and you you kind
of start that i think third fourth fifth
grade is a great time to do that in
terms of resources uh honestly here
here's the thing about it
there's a huge industry that is
predicated on convincing people that
personal finance is really complicated
now i don't want to say
it's super easy for everybody it's easy
if you've been given the right
foundation but you don't need some
endless you know
supply of resources what what i
recommend is
understand just like some basic there's
the basic principles of
saving an emergency fund these these
types of things bloggers like mr money
mustache nick majuli writers like morgan
housel and others there's i'll put i
should really put together a resources
list with maybe like eight books and a
few websites for that will give you 98
of what you need to know it doesn't have
to be complicated and there's a lot of
money spent by people who are convinced
that it is um but stay away from stuff
like you know christian ideologue dave
ramsey who
purports to to give financial advice and
he does and some of the advice is fine
but like he's an ideological right-wing
christian anti-vaxx all this different
stuff you don't you don't need to get
your advice from people like that
um right so so taxes would be something
similar where you think it's
learnable on your own
sorry did you say taxes
uh yeah yeah to do your own taxes
yeah i i noticed that like the tax
industry is um
a large one which is kind of predicated
on the fact that or they're trying to
make you believe that like you need
other people to help you right well
unfortunately i mean
most people really don't need others to
do their taxes most people's tax returns
are very simple but the thing about the
tax code is the companies that make the
software
want to keep the tax code complicated
and it actually is complicated in many
ways so that one's a little bit
different than basic financial literacy
okay gotcha
all right thank you so much for the call
i appreciate it
yeah good to be on all right take care
let's see where do we want to go next a
lot of people want to chat today
um how about ellie from seattle ellie
you're on the air
hey david how's it going it's going well
thank you
can you hear me okay yes i can um a big
fan of the show i've only been watching
um for maybe about two months or so
um and you know i just wanted to say
you know in contrast to all of the
negative voicemails and emails that you
get um i just wanted to say i think
you're doing a great job i feel like
like i said i've only been watching for
a couple months i feel like i've learned
a lot from your show
um and just wanted to say thanks for
all the work you do
have a question sure sure
um but you know it also uh
you know you've kind of inspired me to
start um
making my own uh political videos so
um just thought you might like to know
that fantastic i i'm flattered
um
so i have a divisive question um
might be more divisive than the facial
hair question
so uh i'm originally from new york um
and i know that you know you hail from
you know massachusetts and i think i
remember you saying on the one bonus
show that you're a patriots fan
um
so i have to ask about baseball
okay
are you a red sox fan
yeah i'm a casual red sox fan
baseball is not my big sport it's never
been
oh okay i mean because like i said i
grew up in new york and you know i only
had the two options so of course i'm a
yankees fan so
probably about as casual as you um
that was that was really my only
question okay well yeah i i i
unfortunately my answer is not super
exciting ellie
that's that's okay uh thank you for
taking my call again uh it's good to
talk to you all right you too uh there's
ellie from seattle with a sports
question some people like sports some
people don't
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights
and gives it to you in the form of a
text or audio explainer that you can
consume in 15 minutes with blinkist now
you actually do have time to learn about
all the things you've been wanting to
tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below